[Music]
thank you
in this episode I am going to talk about
my personal top 20 lessons that I
learned from the book emotional
intelligence why it can matter more than
IQ by Daniel Goldman
does IQ Define our destiny in his
groundbreaking bestseller Daniel Goldman
argues that our view of human
intelligence is far too narrow it is not
our IQ but our emotional intelligence
that plays a major role in thought
decision making and individual success
self-awareness impulse control
persistence motivation empathy and
social deafness all are qualities that
Mark people who Excel whose
relationships flourish who can navigate
difficult conversations who become stars
in the workplace
with new insights into the brain
architecture underlying emotion and
rationality Goldman shows precisely how
emotional intelligence can be nurtured
and strengthened in all of us
lesson number one rational and emotional
it is mentioned in the book that there
are two different bits of intelligence
throughout our lives we make decisions
by being influenced by these two types
of intelligence who we are what we do
our reactions depend entirely on it
IQ isn't as important as we think IQ can
get you beyond being a good employee it
makes you graduate from school but they
can't find you a job when you go to the
job interview your diploma cannot answer
the questions during the interview
lesson number three areas of emotional
intelligence emotional intelligence is
responsible for a motivation awareness
empathy and relationships they're all
interconnected and if you're bad at one
you're more likely to be bad at the
others
the emotional brain is stronger the
outer upper part of our brain is the
part where we make rational decisions
while the lower part is the part where
we make emotional decisions no matter
how rational beings we may appear we can
very easily be deceived by the emotional
brain others feelings thanks to our
empathy we can truly understand how
others are feeling if we could not
distinguish between happy or angry
people there would be incredible chaos
Beyond these to basic emotions we must
develop an ability to empathize lesson
number six motivation or motivation
which enables us to endure the problems
we face for a long time is also a
product of emotional intelligence we can
convince ourselves that we can solve
problems we can remain optimistic and
have hope for the future lesson number
seven awareness one of our most
difficult aspects to develop is our
awareness we must practice understanding
how we truly feel we must ask ourselves
questions we must listen to ourselves
relationships cannot be let go it must
be managed this requires Mutual
tolerance and understanding if you know
how to resolve conflicts it turns into a
happy relationship for both parties
our emotions change every moment but the
longer negative emotions stay the more
negatively they affect our lives it
prevents us from being successful in our
work and relationships fortunately these
feelings are not difficult to change
lesson number 10 productivity when your
emotional intelligence gets stronger
your creativity starts to increase
regardless of your field of work you
will start to see serious differences in
your productivity it will increase your
performance longer hours allow you to
work with the same efficacy since we
cannot live a life independent of our
emotions the higher our emotional
intelligence the higher our quality of
life will be we know that successful
managers are experts in managing their
emotional intelligence a commander
cannot direct an entire Army by saying
we are going to war you can't manage a
team by just saying what to do you need
to understand your team's current
feelings and level of motivation you
should encourage them to work you have
to use your emotional intelligence for
all of these average Talent teams that
get along well with each other are more
productive than gifted teams that don't
get along it doesn't matter how well a
team with low emotional intelligence is
in control of the numbers they can't
even decide what to try to do
difficulties at work and in our
relationships put us under stress stress
makes it difficult for us to find
solutions to problems when we can't find
solutions to problems we get more
stressed to get rid of this dead end we
need to know how to manage our stressful
situations
The Secret of long and happy marriages
is sincerity in your feelings if your
marriage was not built on this basis of
honesty from the very beginning it will
begin to crack over the years even small
problems become unsolvable you have to
be emotionally open at the beginning of
the row
leadership does not mean dominance
leading your colleagues to a common goal
and making them believe in the reality
of this purpose successful leaders are
those who can keep their team's
motivation alive for many years you have
to make them desire the work to be done
emotions are all normal anger hatred
love happiness you can understand when
and under what circumstances These
Feelings Will emerge by following
yourself you may have these feelings
depending on how you interpret the
events you encounter
the important thing is to be able to
react independently of your feelings you
may find yourself making promises that
you cannot keep because you are happy or
you may resort to violence when you are
angry
not everyone's level of empathy can be
very good you may be in a difficult
situation immediately you may feel bad
but people may not understand it in
these situations you may need to express
your feelings a little more directly
keep doing what you need to do no matter
how you feel success is achieved by
people who cannot give up no matter what
their feelings and thoughts are don't
let your feelings affect your actions
as soon as you feel a different emotion
try to think before you act because
emotional intelligence moves faster than
rational intelligence it can make you
act irrationally and make you say any
unnecessary words
in this episode we discuss the key
takeaways from the book emotional
intelligence by David Goldman we explore
the definition of emotional intelligence
and its importance in personal and
professional success
we also discussed the five components of
emotional intelligence including
self-awareness self-regulation
motivation empathy and social skills
through examples and case studies we
learned how emotional intelligence can
be developed and improved over time
overall emotional intelligence is a
crucial skill for individuals to develop
and can have a significant impact on
their personal and professional lives
thank you all for tuning in
until next time take care
as always you can head over to our
YouTube channel to subscribe or to sign
up to our email list as well as check
out all the links and resources in the
show notes